Since making his debut as the Dark Knight
in 2016's Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice,
Ben Affleck's name has become as synonymous
with Batman as Jared Leto's has with the Joker,
Margot Robbie's has with Harley Quinn, and
Gal Gadot's has with Wonder Woman.
Affectionately referred to as "Batfleck" by
fans of his contributions to the DC Extended
Universe, Affleck puffed out his chest, mustered
up his courage, and assumed the mantle once
occupied by screen icons Adam West, Michael
Keaton, Val Kilmer, George Clooney, and the
unforgettable Christian Bale, who lead Christopher
Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy.
Now, Affleck is hanging up his cape and cowl
and handing the suit over to someone new - someone
who could be Robert Pattinson.
Yes, rumor has it that Warner Bros. is eyeing
the Twilight Saga alum to become the next
Batman, making his first appearance in director
Matt Reeves' The Batman, the long-gestating
film that Affleck was initially supposed to
lead.
Since appearing in Twilight, Pattinson has
established himself as a legit actor with
acclaimed roles in the films High Life and
Good Time.
And the internet has noticed, taking such
a liking to the idea of Pattinson as Batman
that digital artists have started creating
artwork imagining what the British star would
look like all done up as the Caped Crusader.
Using a Batman concept suit designed by 3D
generalist and CG artist Christophe Lacaux,
Twitter user @NovaMCU shared their creation
on the site on February 11.
Pattinson is just one of many names allegedly
in the running for the role of Batman.
Revenge of the Fans editor-in-chief Mario
Robles claimed on an episode of his The Fanboy
YouTube series that Pattison was up against
the likes of Kick-Ass star Aaron Taylor-Johnson,
Lone Ranger lead Armie Hammer, and Game of
Thrones stars Richard Madden and Kit Harington,
among many others.
But it's Pattinson that seems to have really
captured people's imaginations, with popular
BossLogic wrote,
"A choice that I never would have thought
to try [I've] but been hearing some background
chatter about Robert Pattinson being looked
at, if the [source is] true then all of our
predictions were wrong.
This might be your new Bruce"
It goes without saying that this is all hearsay,
grapevine gossip, unconfirmed chit-chat floating
around the internet.
Warner Bros. hasn't confirmed or denied reports
of Pattinson becoming the next Batman, and
director Reeves hasn't made so much as a peep
about who the next Batman might be.
The studio is apparently looking for someone
younger than Affleck to portray Batman next,
with The Batman said to center around a young
version of the famous DC Comics hero.
Pattinson is only 32 to Affleck's 46 - and
that 14-year age gap falls almost perfectly
in line with past reports that claimed Warner
Bros. wants the newest iteration of Batman
to be 15 to 20 years younger than Affleck,
and the character to be between 25 and 30
years old in the movie.
If Warner Bros. decides to go older, though,
Pattinson might face some serious competition
from a couple of established superstars, namely
Jake Gyllenhaal and Jon Hamm.
Gyllenhaal has been a top contender for the
role of Batman in the past, and though in
2018 he denied he would be the next Batman,
things can change pretty fast in Hollywood.
And as for Hamm, he's reportedly been campaigning
for the role for a long time.
Back in December, 2017, RadarOnline cited
a source that claimed
"Jon knows Ben has faced some criticism over
Batman v Superman and Justice League, and
frankly thinks he'd be better suited for the
job.
This is business for Jon — not personal.
[…] The writing's on the wall, and Jon's
desperate for the gig."
Since Gyllenhaal is 38 and Hamm is 47, it
seems unlikely that either of the two men
will end up leading The Batman.
But who knows?
After Christian Bale left the role, nobody
was expecting Ben Affleck to take it over,
so now that Affleck is leaving, who knows
what Warner Bros. will decide.
It could even be some other name nobody was
expecting to hear.
"Martha!"
Either way, the studio has scheduled The Batman
to soar into theaters on June 25th, 2021,
so fans should expect an announcement soon
about which actor will play the part - whether
it's Pattinson or not.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superheros are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.